on parle de terrorisme maintenant alors
la france aura un jour un musée mémorial
dédié aux victimes des attentats
c'est pour le moment en tout cas son
intitulé c'est l'historien henry rousso
qui a été chargée de dire et de
réfléchir à ce que devrait être ce musée
le figaro publie son interview demain
il répond à toutes les questions que
pose un tel projet question que nous
avons résumé ainsi de façon un peu
provocante peut-être faut-il mettre le
terrorisme au musée laurence marchand
taillade vous êtes favorable à un tel
projet oui et non parce que ça fait
réponse de normand mais je vais
m'expliquer plus précisément oui parce
que je pense que c'est important
les vagues de terrorisme convient mais
elles ne sont pas récentes
et je vois qu'on veut se limiter à allah
au dernier quart du vingtième siècle ou
du voile a cessé pour moi c'est très
limitatif parce que le terrorisme n'est
pas qu'ils se calment en l'occurrence et
non parce que je n'ai pas envie que ça
serve d'une certaine façon de de faire
valoir c'est à dire que finalement
considère que ça y est on a fait le
musée du terrorisme et que finalement
c'est plus la peine d'en parler
voilà et dans dans l'article que j'ai lu
il ya il ya une phrase moi qui me
dérange où on parle de travailler sur la
mémoire plutôt que du devoir de mémoire
travailler sur la mémoire c'est
effectivement bas se pousser à agir
par contre le devoir c'est quelque chose
qui ne vient pas de soi mais qui vient
bien de l'ensemble de la collectivité et
je pense que le devoir de mémoire doit
passer avant même le travail de mémoire
et que les deux doivent de toute façon
un moment est relié ça veut dire qu'il
doit y avoir la pédagogie doit y avoir
de l'éducation et on doit pas se
contenter d'un mémorial pour considérer
qu'on a fait le boulot
vous me donnez l'occasion de passer sept
petits ce petit extrait d'un historien
nicolas offenstadt qui intervenait sur
le sujet alors c'était un sujet un peu
voisins c'est au moment de la polémique
sur maréchal pétain dans la
commémoration du centenaire de 18 mais
il fait cette distinction lui exactement
sur l'histoire et la mémoire
il faut distinguer deux choses c'est je
pense la confusion de départ il ya
l'histoire comme un travail savant sur
le passé vous expliquer ce qui a été un
personnage ou une période et il ya la
mémoire il notamment la mémoire
nationale et c'est sa distinction qui
fondamentale l'histoire vous raconter
tout quand vous êtes historien
quand vous travaillez sur le passé vous
avez évidemment rien à cacher vous
essayez de faire comprendre le mieux
possible avec le maximum de documents
comment les choses se sont passées la
mémoire c'est ce qu'une société décide
de mettre en avant dans l'espace public
et donc c'est un choix c'est un choix
politique c'est un choix moral vouliez
vous faites-le la même analyse il faut
pas mélanger tout mélanger on vous êtes
favorable à ce projet oui si fabre a
écouté quand le cette émission point de
vue elle est très bien préparé parce
qu'on nous envoie les sujets plusieurs
heures à l'avancé dont on comprend son
iphone on lit les sujets et tout mais
quand j'ai eu
faut-il mettre le théorie dans un musée
de cette clause
2 qu'est ce que c'est que cette loi
brille et on m'a dit de si vous voulez
il ya un article qui sort dans le figaro
dommage vous l'envoi par mail et puis un
peu plus tard j'ai reçu l'article pas
mais j'ai déjà compris que votre phrase
comme vous avait gentiment dit qu'il
était une petite simplification dit
comme ça vous pouvez poser la question
vous internautes vous allez avoir une
majorité forte qui va vous répondre que
non mais qu'il s'agit pas de mettre le
terrorisme dans un musée il s'agit de
dire qu'on doit
est ce qu'on doit ou non dédié un musée
à la mémoire du terrorisme et l'a dit
comme ça moi ma réponse est oui et merci
à vos équipes
il va en est content de cette hésitation
ce sujet qu'est ce que c'est que cette
connerie là j'ai vu c'était remarquable
l'interview faite par mois y amène une
barbe du palais russie
[Rires]
non moi je trouve un petit peu curieux
évidemment rendre hommage aux victimes
de terrorisme pas de contenu mais après
il soit un tout petit peu curieux cette
manie de commémorer les choses alors
qu'elles sont pas finies enfin est ce
qu'on imagine le général de gaulle et
churchill dire on va faire un musée de
la lutte contre le nazisme alors qu'ils
étaient à londres et que l'on n'a
toujours pas vaincu analyse le problème
aujourd'hui et du terrorisme il faut
d'abord faut le vaincre après une fois
qu'on l'aura papillon pour il sera
toujours temps de faire des musées ça me
paraît un tout petit peu bizarre comme
façon dont les choses
après moi je suis un peu sceptique sur
le concept scientifique de terrorisme
moi j'ai le sentiment que le terroriste
c'est une technique mais est ce que
c'est un objet scientifique à soi seul
quel est le point commun entre le
terrorisme de ravachol alors on n'ira
pas jusque là enfin des anarchistes les
terroristes
la l2 l'om paie l'autorisent des
islamistes le terrain des suprémacistes
blancs dont il pas offert un grand
machin on va dire ouh là c'est très mal
moins évidemment c'est très mal mais
qu'est ce que ça va apprendre
aujourd'hui la vraie bataille dans
laquelle nous sommes engagés c'est la
lutte contre le terroriste islamiste
parce qu'il faut faire un musée je ne
crois pas mais encore en tout cas il
faut le dire
et puis c'est peut-être s'intéresser à
ça et aux côtes mais faire ce grand
melting-pot à part le côté de bons se
rassure en disant qu'on est très gentil
parce qu'on n'aime pas les méchants je
vois pas bien l'intérêt effectivement
mélange des genres entre mémoire et
hommage aux victimes
et histoire je comprends moi je
comprends tout à fait l'intérêt d'un
mémorial
je pense que c'est fait que ça peut être
effectivement important et pour les
familles des victimes et pour l'ensemble
de la nation française sur le musée je
rejoins un peu
vous remarquer lors sans avoir encore eu
la chance de lire l'interview de demain
mais est effectivement un musée sont un
sujet présent j'attends de voir ce que
ça avec les articles contenus dans
heroes sol historiens qui donc pilote ce
projet c'est dire aujourd'hui la mémoire
et il l'a fait lui-même le chemin sur
deux c'est à dire la mémoire fait partie
de l'histoire
en plus les musiques ne sont pas
toujours parce qu'au début j'ai été
impressionné par la force de l'argument
de talent et qui brise est sûr c'est que
le passé c'est vrai que le volley club
tu aurais pas fait mais sans guère
mondiale en 1940
mais il ya quand même des musées qui
traite autant présent aussi regarder un
des musées préféré par le vaste public
madame tussauds ou le musée grévin chez
nous à chaque fois qu'il ya un
personnage bas tam scientifique de vue
géographique d'attraction touristique
allons bon oui bien sûr c'est
sympathique mais vu le mémorial du
11-septembre à new york et ce n'est pas
qu'un lieu de culture et je pense que
c'est ça qu'il faut rappeler c'est que
là on va on va vers un lieu de mémoire
et en l'occurrence moi ce qui me
surprend c'est qu'on est trois ans après
charlie voilà et qu'en l'occurrence
quatre ans déjà c'était que 2015 et
quatre ans et que maintenant on est de
plus en plus de gens qui peuvent se
prétend ne pas être charlie donc je
pense que c'est important
au moins ce titre là c'est de faire
grande et de faire passer
l'horreur de la chose est la raison pour
laquelle il est important de le
continuer mais faire une violence c'est
là le danger beaucoup plus la transposer
les mêmes actions dia que vermette
georges des corses et
les corses qu'est-ce qu'il yad'autres la
rue copernic parce que c'est un peu
bizarre comme sensation et qui lui dit
que conques en cause sur les lieux du
bataclan ou de charlie il ya un an va
pour commémorer les victimes mortes
entre tous ces gens là si on dirait
qu'on soit des victimes du terrorisme
c'est aussi le fait qu'ils soient
victimes du terrorisme parce que
français et je pense que ça il faut le
rappeler qu'on puisse à trois logos
genre je vais danser pâques si on dirait
comme ça les corses s'est pas même si sa
présence
olivier briller alizée plus apprendre à
mes petits enfants en les emmenant au
musée comme je leur apprendrait si
j'étais un grand père qui je ne suis pas
des choses essentielles sur la peinture
comme je leur apprendrait ce qu'a été la
shoah leur apprendre ce quelques même
dans une démocratie il ya des forces qui
refuse la liberté le dialogue et qui
auront quoi des armées qui détruisent
des innocents et en voilà quelques
heures de ces quarante dernières années
je vois pas ce que ça a de mauvais
départ mais une fois de plus ça ne peut
être utile que s'il ya de la pédagogie à
côté et entend grand père c'est très
bien de faire je pense que c'est aussi à
l'état à l'école de faire ce genre de
travail j'avais posé la question du
musée de mémorial du 11-septembre à new
york certains d'entre vous l'ont visitée
j'avais look et des points de vue je ne
se résout les doigts pour aller vérifier
sur place
non non plus dans vous tézier olivier
que 12 internautes allait être contre
c'est effectivement une grande majorité
69% d'entre vous alors mais la question
était comme on le dit un peu caricatural
faut-il mettre le terrorisme au musée
préciser quand même qu'un musée mémorial
dédié aux victimes allait voir le jour
69% d'entre vous
trouve que pas que ce soit une bonne
idée bertrand nous dit les musées nous
raconte le passé le terrorisme lui est
toujours bien présent ladino en installe
une hiérarchie au sein des morts ce qui
tombe sous le coup du terrorisme mérite
amusé et les autres non le problème
question d'utilisation des mots et de
fond mais est ce que ce sera ce que sera
ce projet vous voiler le mémorial de la
shoah c'est bien un mémorial de la shoah
ce pas un musée de la choix pour le coup
j'ai amené mes enfants en relativement
jeune et vous avez un parcours
pédagogique douloureux pédagogique pour
l'heure pour transmettre une mémoire et
il ya effectivement que ce qui rejoint
la station vous passiez dans les roseaux
instinct lieu de réflexion sur
l'histoire sur la france et sur la
transmission
c'est de fait c'est pas mal c'est pas un
musée un mu ce n'est pas un musée comme
le louvre est un musée comme le musée de
l'histoire de lisa grévin mais comme le
musée de l'histoire de l'immigration on
est c'est un concept qui est différent
là il faut probablement attendre savoir
ce qu'est ce qui est résultera de cette
mission mais s'il ya il ya une nuance
france entre le mémorial et musées
question servira juste un mot une phrase
il ya un problème dans l'interprétation
des sondages si vous faites alors
sondage auprès des français sondage
auprès des lecteurs du figaro mais si
vous poser comme question emmanuel
macron diable de décidé de passer à
l'heure d'été est ce que tu aurais pu le
changement d'heure est ce que vous êtes
pour
pour 45 50 % on va décider de passer on
passe à l'heure d'été trucs pour 80%
c'est quand même l'effet de refus sur
toute décision perçue comme émanant du
pouvoir s'il pourra compter j'avais
milieu de maquereau dans nos questions
bon ben on comprend qu'au moyen bien la
déception quant au contenu intéressant
si je dis toujours ce qu'on peut pas
près l'heure d'été à l'heure d'hiver
ils disent tous ceux arrêtés parce que
l'été c'est plus sympa pidoux cinq
minutes pour en parler une messe a été
célébrée ce matin à l'occasion des 45
ans de sa mort emmanuel macron et
jusqu'à destin était à la cérémonie et
donc le 15 juin ce sera l'élection
l'anniversaire de l'élection du
successeur du général de gaulle à
l'elysée c'était donc qu'en 1969 il ya
50 ans olivier duhamel georges pompidou
redevient à la mode
je suis pas sûr vraiment je pense que
mme étonnant à quel point ce président a
été effacée dans la mémoire collective
alors que dans le fond c'est peut-être
un de ceux auxquels on a le moins de
choses à reprocher de parce que bon
évidemment du pas parce qu'il n'a pas
présidé très longtemps ce qui est de 5
années mais aussi parce que ça a été
pris dans laquelle les conservateurs
comme les progressistes peuvent trouver
quelque chose qui leur convient c'est le
les conservateurs c'est facile de le
dire parce que surtout dans la dernière
période et s'est un peu recroquevillés
notamment à cause de la maladie mais les
progressistes c'est lui qui a par
exemple est votée la loi de
mensualisation des salaires qui a très
profondément changé